[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public 90
minutes de débat de chronique et de
reportage pour donner du sens à
l'actualité comme tous les soirs du
lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h sur public
Senna une fête de village qui tourne au
drame c'était il y a 10 jours à crépool
dans la Drome et le fait d'hiver est
devenu depuis un fait politique celui
d'une France rurale qui serait prise
pour cible par des délinquants venus de
banlieu Eric Zemour crie au francooside
des militants d'extrême droite
organisent plusieurs expéditions
pulitives dans le quartier d'origine des
agresseur à Roman suriser entre violence
débridée et récupération politique on
analyse les conséquences de la mort du
jeune Thomas dans une minute et puis
pour notre second débat c'est un droit
de suite que je vous propose 5 ans après
les gilets jaunes les gilets jaunes
n'avit n'était pas un simple mouvement
social les gilets jaunes c'était une
révolte c'était une révolte contre
toutes les
injustices que reste-t-il du mouvement
des gilets jaunes un parti en a-t-il
profiter que sont devenus ces milliers
de cahiers de doléan censé permettre de
traduire politiquement les grands débat
d'Emmanuel Macron on répond à toutes ces
questions avec nos invités experts dans
tro quart d'heure
mais d'abord donc l'histoire d'un
village de la drô un village endeuillé
qui voit défiler les personnalités
politiques de tout bord Flora sauvage
une semaine après la mort de Thomas 16
ans tué d'un coup de couteau en marche
d'une fête de village à crépole dans la
Drome les circonstances de sa mort sont
encore floues ce qui n'a pas empêché de
susciter une cascade de réaction
virulente de la droite à l'extrême
droite ce weekend des groupuscules
identitaires venus de toute la France se
sont retrouvés à roman turiser où était
scolarisé Thomas pour en découdre avec
les jeunes du quartier sensible de la
monnaie ces jeunes de cité qui se sont
comportés se sont mémau comme des
prédateurs sont venus pour planter des
blancs et sont venus pour
plan des jeunes les procès en
récupération politique sont là pour
masquer la réalité et généralement ils
sont utilisés par ceux qui ont une
responsabilité morale dans la situation
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas voir faen
Rousel dénonce lui une
instrumentalisation politique de la part
de l'extrême droite je vois qu'il y a
des responsables politiques d'extrême
droite vous les avez cité qui eux se
saisissent de ce drame pour en faire un
projet politique et puis je va pas dire
jeter de l'huile sur le feu dépêché sur
place Olivier verrand le porte-parole du
gouvernement a souligné la gravité du
moment ce qui a coûté la vie à Thomas
n'est ni un fait divher ni une simple r
Rix en marge d'un bal de village c'est
un drame qui nous fait courir le risque
d'un basculement de notre société si
nous ne sommes pas à la hauteur à ce
stade de l'enquête selon le procureur de
Valence les violences qui ont conduit à
la mort de Thomas seraiit survenu pour
un motif futile et non dans le cadre
d'une attaque préméditée 10 suspects ont
été mis en examen et plus de 100 témoins
ont été
entendus quandtin fait d'hiver devient
un fait politique c'est le thème de
notre débat avec Florent vadillot
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes président du
sac de réflexion l'éterie enseignant à
sciencep Laurence deerve bonsoir et
bienvenue directrice du cercle de
réflexion destin comm Victor de Lage
bonsoir bienvenue le fondateur de
l'Institut teram qui est aussi un cercle
de réflexion dédié à l'étude des des
territoires Mathieu croissandau bonsoir
Mathieu éditorialiste politique bon la
récupération politique d'un fait divers
c'est pas nouveau Florent vadiillot
est-ce qu'un cran supplémentaire a été
pour vous franchis depuis des jours un
cran supplémentaire pas nécessairement
mais en tout cas un clou qui est de plus
en plus enfoncé par certains
responsables politiques qui est
d'ailleurs repris par bien au-delà de
l'extrême droite c'est-à-dire
l'inconscient qui qui a derrière et Eric
Zemour pour le coup n'a pas cette inconc
là c'est le francoside c'est-à-dire que
tant Eric cioti que de nombreux autres
responsables ont indiqué que la
provenance géographique donc ethnique
dans leur tête des assaillants des
meurtriers était lié à une intention de
tuer un français un blanc donc en
légitimant le francoside et on se rend
compte que depuis la campagne
présidentielle de 2022 on a comme ça un
glissement de la droite républicaine qui
reprend peu à peu les thèmes de
l'extrême droite vous c'est ça ce qui
vous choque le plus pas tant d'entendre
ERC Zemour dire ça plutôt d'entendre ERC
CTI embrayer mais Erric Zemour c'est son
fond de commerce donc qu'il le disent
c'est attendu le fronttion le
rassemblement national qu'il le disent
c'est également attendu ça valide le
discours qu'ils tiennent depuis 10 15
ans 20 ans et plus récemment depuis pour
Éric pour Éric Zemour en revanche que
les thèmes de l'extrême droite les le
vocabulaire de l'extrême droite les
impensé de l'extrême droite pass
systématiquement dans la bouche de la
droite républicaine ça veut dire qu'il y
a une perméabilité et que ça infuse dans
la population et donc Infiné on est en
train de créer des convulsions à tort ou
à raison sans doute à tort et et qui ont
des répercussions très fortes chez les
gens parce qu'à force de répéter les
mêmes messages et bien ils finissent par
devenir naturel Laurence de nerveau on
parle souvent de de de polarisation
est-ce qu'elle est à l'œuvre dans de
plus en plus d'événements pas seulement
des fait d'hiver d'ailleurs absolument
il me semble que c'est aujourd'hui
quasiment systématique quel que soit le
fait d'actualité dont il est question
que ce soit une grande crise
internationale ou ce qu'on appelle ici
un divers et je suis d'accord qu'on peut
en débattre le mécanisme est toujours le
même tout de suite on dessine deux camps
on oppose un camp à un autre camp et on
donne l'injonction aux Français de
choisir leur camp mais pas seulement de
choisir leur camp de également s'opposer
de manière de plus en plus virulente et
hosyle à l'autre camp et ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle et de plus en plus rapide
aussi avant éventuellement de savoir
exactement ce qui s'est passé c'est ça
et ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la
polarisation affective
c'est-à-dire c'est pas seulement une
opposition binaire c'est cette hostilité
cette animosit à l'égard du camp adverse
et ça en fait c'est alimenté c'est
nourri par ce qu'on appelle ce que les
angloaxons appellent identity politics
qui est une méthode une façon en fait
d'exacerber et d'instrumentaliser nos
conceptions de notre identité à des fins
politique et ça c'est extrêmement
dangereux et on pourrait décrypter plus
précisément la façon dont procède
l'extrême droite dans le cas de Crépol
qui commence à être très documenté et
très précise oui c'est c'est c'est
l'objet de ce débat on rentrera
évidemment dans dans le ta Victor de
Lage si ce fait d'hiver il domine
l'actualité depuis 10 jours c'est aussi
parce qu'il y a il y a un symbole
presque un temporelle de la France au
milieu il y a la fête de village quoi il
y a la fête de village effectivement
vous avez raison de de le souligner qui
fait référence à tout un univers un
imaginaire lié à une certaine
insouciance chez les Français alors pour
autant on sait ça il y a eu beaucoup de
il y a eu certaines violences lors de de
certaines fêtes de village
historiquement
mais néanmoins on a franchi un cap au
niveau de du degré d'intensité de cette
violence c'est une c'est une violence
urbaine extérieure qui a été importé
dans cette France des territoires dans
cette
France des village et j'aimerais
rappeler néanmoins que à mon sens on
nassiste pas forcément à un tournant on
assiste à une une nouvelle étape parce
que quand on regarde les chiffres en
réalité cette cette violence dans les
territoires ruraux elle ne fait que
augmenter depuis une vingtaine d'années
il y a les données du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui sont en accès libre et
qui montent qui montrent que
effectivement euh sur l'ensemble des de
la délinquence et des actes violents qui
sont commis à l'échelle du territoire
français vous avez 27 % des agressions
sexuelles 24 % des cambriolages et 20 %
des agressions physiques volontaires euh
qui sont réalisés euh dans les
territoires ruraux donc on voit bien que
ce n'est pas quelque chose de de nouveau
mais étapê importation de territoires
urbains vers les territoires ruraux oui
parce que à mon sens il y a une une
redéfinition un petit peu géographique
de cette violence urbaine qui pendant
des années s'est développé s'est propagé
dans les villes de taille moyenne ou
dans les petites villes on l'a
d'ailleurs vu lors des émeutes l'été
passé euh beaucoup de de Bi ou de
personnes ont été victimes alors
d'agression euh dans des petites villes
et des moyennes villes ce qui n'était
pas le cas lors des émeutes de 2005 euh
là la différence c'est que c'est un une
sorte euh d'assaut à l'arme blanche qui
est commis dans un village de 500
habitants et qui justement ruine un
petit peu tout tout cet imaginaire
auquel les Français sont sont très
attachés qui est lié au au au village
pour le porte-parole du gouvernement il
s'agit je le cite hein d'un drame qui
nous fait courir le risque d'un
basculement de notre société euh Florent
vadiillot euh est-ce que quand Olivier
verrant prend ces termes-là est-ce qu'il
rentre lui aussi dans une rhtorique
d'affrontement entre communautés d'une
certaine façon il va pas jusque là je
pense pas qu'on puisse accuser Olivier
verérrant de de de d'abonder dans le
sens du discours de l'extrême droite il
il note que depuis une dizaine d'années
à chaque fois qu'il y a eu ce genre
d'événement les émeutes mais le meurtre
de la jeune Lola par exemple à chaque
fois il y a eu une convulsion
supplémentaire qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
quand on regarde les intentions de vote
quand on regarde la désinhibition de
certains propos de fait il y a une telle
crise passtiion dans la société que
certains s'interrogent sur la capacité
de
basculement sur l'acte violent ou en
tout cas sur un acte subversif et je
fais passer le vote extrême droite dans
ces actes subversifs donc il a raison de
montrer que cette convulsion est en
train de se poursuivre et que au regard
du travail de SAP que l'on peut voir
chez certains acteurs politiques il y a
un risque et ce risque n'est pas neutre
mais est-ce qu'il y a parce qu'on va
parler évidemment des des conséquences
ensuite C ces militants d'extrême droite
qui qui sont allés à roman sur réserve
mais dans d'autres villes aussi en
voulant défendre la la France est-ce que
vous reprenez quand même ce risque de
sorte de guerre civile de communauté qui
se rendrait pour coup pour coup Laurenz
Nervo est-ce que c'est ce à quoi on est
en train d'assister peut-être soyons
prudents en germe en amorce si c'est le
cas ce n'est pas tant du fait de la
violence elle-même que du commentaire de
cette violence et de son interpré qui me
semble être de plus en plus toxique et
en cela je ne suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec l'interprétation qui a été
formulée tout à l'heure par Victor deage
mais nous pourrons y revenir voudrais
commencer par vous proposz une sorte de
décryptage on peut essayer de
décortiquer la façon dont l'extrême
droite ça je veux bien qu'on y revienne
après si si ça vous dérange pas non non
mais parce que on va on va vraiment y
consacrer un chapitre le mécanisme de la
récupération si si on peut dire ça
qu'est-ce qui vous en quoi vous étiez
pas d'accordc c'est vraiment ce terme de
de violence importée qui laisse entendre
qu'il y aurait des territoires bien
distincts qui seraient très différents
les uns des autres qui serait même assez
euh enfin et qui serait distinct
géographiquement or regardons de près ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est que le
jeune Thomas et le jeune qui est le
principal suspect de son meurtre allit
dans des lycées qui étaient à quelques
centaines de mètres l'un de l'autre et
que le l'endroit où habitaient
exactement les jeunes qui sont
aujourd'hui arrêtés était est encore
flou en réalité donc cette notion en
fait de la France rurale qui serait la
France paisible la France Pacifique est
une vision à mon sens qui est quelque
peu idéalisée et fantasmée et qui ne
correspond pas parfaitement à la rité et
c'est cette vision un peu idéalisée qui
est très largement instrumentalisé par
l'extrême droite et par ailleurs la
violence dans les campagnes dans la
France rurale elle existe aussi mais
tout dépend de quelle violence on veut
parler si par exemple on veut parler des
féminicides on sait qu'aujourd'hui plus
de la moié des féminicides ont lieu dans
des zones rurales ce qui est une
proportion bien plus importante que la
proportion de la population qui vit en
zone rurale voilà donc là il peut y
avoir aussi toujours des effets de
cadrage auquel il faut faire extrêmement
attention là on parle d'un épisode
unique parler faire une généralisation à
mon sens c'est dangereux maie vous venez
de de dire le mot qui est important
parce que dans la récupération politique
d'unf c'est pas nouveau on y assiste
depuis toujours depuis le 19e et même
avant je pense pas pivoise pour la
campagne 2002 VO qui nous faire croire
que toutes les personnes âgées sont en
insécurité sur l'ensemble du territoire
et la récupération elle procède toujours
de deux mouvements d'abord une forme de
précipitation parce qu'il faut être le
premier à planter son drapeau le premier
à qualifier le fait là on a une
explosion de violence qui est absolument
dramatique dans une salle desfites de
campagne et tout de suite on arrive et
on met ses mots francoside pour Éric
Zemour radia pour Marine Le Pen ça sort
nul par il y a des témoignages il y a
des personnes agressées qui qui
j'entends bien j'entends bien mais tout
de suite on plante les mots pour nourrir
le RC idéologique parce qu'ensuite après
la précipitation on verra ce que donne
l'enquête on verra bien ce que donne
l'enquête parfois l'enquête confirme les
intuitions de certains parfois ça ne les
confirme pas mais donc c'est pour
nourrir deess logique et l'autre l'autre
l'autre levier c'est la généralisation
ou l'extrapolation c'est considérer qu'à
partir de cette explosion de violence on
peut en faire une France en miniature et
considérer que partout dans le pays il y
a si on caricature des petits blancs
tranquilles en milieu rural bien
sympathique qui se font agresser par
d'affreus enfants deimmigration de cités
populaires euh c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est complètement binaire c'est
simpliste parce qu'il faut que ça marche
c'est la polarisation que vous décrivez
tout à l'heure on est dans l'indignation
et non pas forcément dans l'explication
mais ça ne reflète pas la réalité du
pays le pays n'est pas à feu assant
quand j'entends quelqu'un comme Eric
cotti patron DLR dire hier on n plus en
sécurité nulle part en France euh c'est
une généralisation qui est pas digne
d'un d'un d'unun d'un patron de parti de
gouvernement d'une certaine façon on est
en sécurité en France il y a des fait
d'ivers il y a des accidents il y a des
choses horribles mais on est on est
globalement en sécurité en France c'est
pas le terme francoside c'est planté des
blancs c'est c'est les mots qui ont été
mis alors je sais pas moi je suis pas
juge ou policier mais dans la bouche de
certains des témoins de de l'agression
de crépole planté des blancs alors
justement est-ce qu'il y avait
clairement des intentions racistes chez
ceux qui sont qui ont voulu entrer dans
cette fête de village l'avocat de quatre
des agresseurs présumés quatre des
hommes mis dans examen ni cette
dimension du dossier on l'écoute
une étude rapide de la procédure permet
de dire dans un premier temps que
beaucoup de contre de vérités ont pu
être indiqué tant dans certaines
tribunes politiqu que dans les réseaux
sociaux je tiens à rappeler un principe
qui est absolument essentiel cardinal je
dirais dans la procédure pénale
française c'est le principe de la
présomption
d'innocence ni le réquisitoire
introductif ni les fait la qualification
des faits pour lesquels les personnes
ont été mis en examen ne retiennent la
circonstance aggravante d'une
préméditation ou d'un quelconque mobile
raciste h Victor de l'â ce sera la
justice de de de trancher sauf que comme
vient de le dire Mathieu tout le monde
veut planter son drapeau veut réagir le
plus vite possible sur internet non
c'est c'est ça tout l'enjeu
effectivement on voit bien qu'il y a une
une récupération d'ailleurs de de toutes
part on a vu la la une du du JDD
justement ce weekend qui nommait les
personnes présumé présumé coupable donc
il y a une extrême radicalisation de la
part d'un camp on peut aussi estimer
malgré tout qu'il y a eu une tentative
d'édulcoration euh notamment du monde
médiatique par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé pour rappel si on prend monde
médiatique c'est un certains médias en
tout cas vous avez raisg mais ça dépend
si on est sur quelle chaîne d'info on
est ça dépend quel journal on lit diche
come quand on parle de on a tendance à
parler de la classe politique on est
d'accord ça m'est arrivé de le faire
aussi là louver mais vous avez raison en
tout cas de de le préciser je citerai un
exemple moi qui m'a quand même
interpellé c'est c'est le monde qui a
commencé à parler de cette affaire là
sur leur site le M
à 16h40 en classant d'ailleurs dans dans
la catégorie fait divers et donc ça peut
aussi malgré
tout prêter à à confusion par rapport au
traitement médiatique pour vous c'est
plus qu'un fait divers c'est un fait
politique pour moi on est dans un fait
politique dans un fait sociétal parce
que comme l'a dit d'ailleurs ce matin
Olivier verrand la question ce n'est pas
d'être là à tel endroit un mauvais
moment ce qui se joue derrière ça c'est
qu'on a comme vous l'avez souligné dans
une petite commune rurale des jeunes
gens qui sont venus sur un parking avec
des couteaux alors effectivement la
procédure expliquera ce qui s'est
réellement passé mais à partir du moment
où vous avez des personnes qui sont
armées et qui lors de ces violences
disent qu'elles sont là pour planter du
blanc ça signifie quand même quelque
chose
j'ajouteris oui c'est ça il faut
préciser que cette phraseé du blanc ne
fait pas partie aujourd'hui des
arguments des des élé qui sont confirmés
par l'enquête
c'est une dizain de Témo il y a
plusieurs témoins qui mais mais pour
l'instant c'est pas dans le c'est pas
dans la procédure judiciaire voilà c'est
pour ça qu'on a donné la parole à
l'avocat tout à l'heure et et simplement
sur la récupération politique et vous
l'avez précisé ça ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui moi ce qui me ce qui me
désole c'est que sur un événement comme
celui-ci justement les partis politiques
devraient faire front
commun je le dis naïvement mais
malheureureusement que l'on obser thème
qui qui qui favorise la polarisation
c'est c'est la délinquence la violence
et l'immigration et alors quand on lit
les deux oui mais ce que ce que moi ce
qui me chagrine c'est que selon les
affaires on a le sentiment on a
l'impression que selon son camp on doit
choisir son martyre on l'avait vu lors
de l'affaire tragique aussi de Naël et
d'ailleurs ça a des répercussions sur la
société dans son ensemble parce que vous
aviez une France de la cagnote pour les
policiers et une France de la cagnotte
pour les proches et les familles
de de Naël donc il y a une vraie
polarisation au niveau politique au
niveau médiatique qui qui aussi déchire
et participe à la déconstruction de la
société alors vous avez dit vous l'avez
dit he il y a une vraie question qui qui
nous concerne aussi nous journalistes
nous médias c'est la question de de des
des noms des prénoms même pour être
précis des agresseurs présumis je
propose à Steve Jourdain de nous
rejoindre sur ce
plateau bonsoir Steve bienvenue à vous
on va donc s'intéresser à ces responsa
politique qui se focalise depuis
quelques jours sur les les prénoms des
suspects oui ça a été très rapide he
très très rapide 48 he après le meurtre
de Thomas l'extrême droite est monté au
créneau on ne connaît alors absolument
rien du profil des suspects mais peu
importe pour le parti reconquête vous
savez le parti d'Éric Zemour les
patronymes devraient nous permettre d'y
voir un peu plus clair écoutez je vous
prends le Paris mais peut-être que je me
trompe que les les suspects en
l'occurrence aont auront des noms à
connotation magrébienes auront des noms
à connotation africaines ISS
d'immigration dans les jours qui suivent
la la quête va continuer oui vendredi le
Figaro revient sur les tiraillements au
sein de la majorité à propos du drame on
y apprend que Gérald haranin aurait dit
la chose suivante non ça c'est la une du
GDD qu'on verra après Gérald haranin qui
aurait dit la chose suivante à l'un de
ses collègues ministres il fait
référence aux suspects qui ont été
placés la veille en garde à vue ils sont
français mais pas un seul pas un seul n
un nom à consonance française vous
verrez ce que ça suscitera dans le pays
cette affaire traumatique légitimement
no compatriotes il faut remettre des
règles et de l'ordre sinon le pays
partira à volo fin de citation et alors
on en estd en tout cas certain que
Gérald Arman aurait choisi siamment de
cacher la liste des noms des suspects
bah pour ERC zimour c'est très clair oui
on va voir ce le tweet que le patron de
reconquête a fait dans la foulée le
patron de reconquête du parti il parle
même de franc aide vous l'évoquiez tout
à l'heure alors même que tout les
suspects ont la nationalité française
hier on va voir effectivement cette une
du JDD le Journal du Dimanche qui
revient sur cette affaire le journal
promet de révéler la vérité sur une
omerta dans les pages intérieures on
retrouve les prénoms des suspect dans
cette affaire on va les donner
puisqu'ils sont maintenant entrés dans
le débat public il y aurait Shahid
Yassir Matis feissal Quider Yanis voilà
les noms des principaux suspects selon
le JDD la police et les autorités ne
confirment pas ces informations ce qui
est sûr ce qui est avéré Thomas c'est
que six personnes ont été incarcérées en
détention provisoire ce weekend sur fond
de polémique le procureur de Valence a
tenu à faire une mise au point samedi
soir par communiqué à ce stade
l'élucidation des faits commis à Crépol
n'est pas achevé le scénario même des
passages à l'acte les mobiles et
l'identification de tous les tous les
auteurs des faits ne seraient pas ne
seraiit se résumé à des dénonçation sans
preuve des spéculations ou des
interprétations attives voilà pour ce
communiquer le procureur qui refuse de
donner les détails sur l'identité des
principaux suspects il s'agit selon lui
et bien de protéger l'enquête en
répuique Thas on est condamné pour ce
qu'on fait et non en raison de son nom
et de son prénom le procureur a
simplement rappelé un principe de base
de la République merci Steve Jourdain
pour toutes ces informations Florent
vedillot je vous voyais réagir quand on
a affiché les les prénoms faut-il les
publier ces prénoms bah à ce stade non
parce que ce sont des présummés
innocents premier élément pour
deuxièmement non c'est une information
comme une autre alors je vais y venir ce
n'est pas une information communautre
puisque c'est une information qui est
protégée par le secret de l'enquête et
donc je serai procureur de la République
de crpol enfin compétent en terme de
crpol je poursuivrai le JDD pour
violation du secret de l'enquête parce
que cette violation là elle n'est pas
destinée à informer le public et la la
jurisprudence de la Cour euréaine des
droit dehomme elle est très claire on
peut révéler un secret lorsqu'il y a un
intérêt public supérieur en l'espèce la
révélation du JDD n'a pas pour objectif
d'informer le public elle a pour
objectif d'orienter la perception d'un
drame donc c'est une désinformation ou à
tout le MIN une malinformation pas
d'accord avec vous je pense que donner
ses prénoms sans en faire un acte
militant comme le JDD a pu le faire en
disant brise l'omerta et cetera c'est
c'est un acte journalistique mais j'ai
on aura un désaccord sur ce point-là
parce que au regard de la sensibilité du
contexte au regard des ratonades auxquel
on a pas on est on est on est soupçonné
justement de cacher une verité que le
procureur mais j'entends mais dans ce
cas-là c'est un autre pour moi c'est un
autre sujet qui est posé c'est le
problème de la communication judiciaire
je pense que le procureur de la
République et ça je ne m'ingère pas dans
une procédure juste de sa communication
je pense que le procureur de la
République a commis des erreurs de
communication il a voulu à la fois
rétablir certains faits et garder le
silence sur d'autres en précisant qu'il
gardait le silence sur d'autres dans une
période de crise c'est ce qu'il y a de
pire à faire parce qu'en réalité vous
mettez plus le projecteur sur ce que
vous cachez que sur ce que vous gardez
donc je pense qu'il y a un problème de
communication judiciaire parce que les
procureurs aujourd'hui sont en train de
courir après les faits en toujours en
rétablissant la vérité et cetera je me
permets de prendre un contrepo d'une
affaire qui a eu lieu ce weekend et qui
aurait pu faire le même tinamar l'homme
qui est mort à Dijon d'une d'un
règlement de compte visiblement entre
bande rival oui sur un point de Deal et
qui a pris une balle perdue é dans son
appartement ex la conférence de presse
du procureur de la République a été
exemplaire parce qu'il a donné toutes
les informations qui étaient nécessaires
et il a fermé tous les sujets qui
pouvaient être ouvert la preuve il n'y a
eu aucune récupération politique alors
qu'il aurait pu y avoir la même chose
donc je pense qu'il faut que les
magistrats les procureurs communiquent
mieux en période de crise mais ça n'est
pas au journalistes d'orienter ce genre
de de propos c'est un dans un monde
idéal mais je suis aussi optimiste que
vous l'étiez tout à l'heure on devrait
pouvoir donner ses prénoms s que ce soit
un débat mais Mathieu je veux bien vous
entendre là-dessus parce que si on les
donne pas on met encore plus le
projecteur dessus ça ça met ceux qui ne
les donnent pas dans une position de
défensive et dans dans un soupçon
d'omerta or qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire on donne les
six prénoms de ces de ces de ces
agresseurs il se trouve présumé il se
trouve que peut-être aucun d'entre eux
n'est à consonance française et alors
qu'est-ce qu'on en tire comme conclusion
tous les gens qui ont des prénoms à
consonance nonom française sont des
assassins en puissance c'est ridicule je
cette généralisation c'est ça qu'il faut
combattre c'est de la même façon que que
quand parce que c'est c'est c'est les
mêmes logiques à à l'autre bord de de
l'autre côté de l' chiqué c'estàdire que
vous avez un flic qui va faire une
bavure policière on va dire bah tous les
flics sont des c'est systémiques et tous
les flics sont des racistes qui veulent
tirer sur sur sur les délinquants non de
la même façon il peut ça peut très bien
être si délinquants avec des noms
d'origine à consonance de non française
et alors qu'est-ce qu'on en tire comme
conclusion comme généralisation rien il
y a il y a rien à hon tirer allez votre
avis à à l'une et à l'autre lance de
nervveau pour commencer vre rapport à
l'information que qu' question
absolumement absolument mais surtout
rappelons-nous sur cette question des
prénoms comment nous en sommes arrivés
là Éric Zemour pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2022 avait fait la
proposition que l'on nindisent les
prénoms non français d'abord qu'est-ce
qu'un prénom non français et ensuite euh
où va-t-on quelle est cette cette fuite
en avant absolument délirante qui
essentialise nos identités et là-dessus
je vous rejoins ce n'est pas seulement
le fait de la droite et de l'extrême
droite cette essentialisation des
identités elle existe aussi du côté de
la gauche radicale et elle est
absolument toxique et dangereuse voilà
ça c'est pour rappeler comment on en est
arrivé là je revient sur la façon
justement dont l'extrême droite impose
un cadrage interprétatif il y a quatre
étapes qu'on peut distinguer la première
c'est on plante le décor et le décor
c'est en l'occurrence dans le cas de
crépool un cas pur et parfait c'est la
France éternelle la France d'Épinal le
village rural le clocher le jeune blanc
le joueur de rugby 2uxème étape c'est le
plus important à mon sens le séquençage
l'interprétation précède l'ffet comme
l'a très justement expliqué votre
collègue à l'instant on impose une
interprétation avant que lesffit soit
connu et ça ce n'est pas possible en
fait c'est absolument pas possible
troisième étape on va généraliser on va
élargir le cadre d'un événement on va le
lier à d'autres événements au niveau
national c'est la référence au meurtre
de la jeune Lola et même on va en faire
un un un on va invoquer un référentiel
mondial Marion barichal a parlé de
guerre civilisationnelle et la dernière
dimension c'est l'iconographie qui vient
en appui d'un argumentaire en très très
rapidement et c'est assez impressionnant
et c'est par exemple des analystes comme
Raphaël lorka qui pointent ça également
en fait on voit surgir sur les réseaux
sociaux une profusion euh de d'affiches
avec un une injonction à les placardés
dans les rues de vidéos souvenirs et
cetera qui vont appuyer euh cette
interprétation et le problème c'est que
ce cadrage interprétatif qui est imposé
par l'extrême droite ensuite il permet
de justifier les épisodes comme celui
qu'on a vu samedi à roman suriser de euh
de de de violence de de euh de de groupe
de groupusculle d'extrême droite ça
permet de de les justifier sur sur le
prétexte qu'il s'agirait de d'une
attitude défensive en fait voilà donc
c'est c'est vraiment ça ce à quoi on a
assisté VCT deage votre avis toujours
sur ce même thème évidemment je je suis
plutôt d'accord avec ce qui a été dit je
je crois de toute manière qu'il y a il
devrait y avoir non pour pas les publier
à mon sens il devrait y avoir deux
temporalités euh différence la
temporalité politique notamment dans une
société hypermédiatisée comme la notre
avec des réseaux sociaux
qui est vraiment une société politique
du temps court et à côté la justice qui
elle devrait s'inscrire dans une
temporalité plus longue moi ce qui m'a
c'est vrai que cette cette une m'a m'a
choqué ce qui m'a aussi interpellé par
ailleurs c'est quand je crois que c'est
Gérard armmanin qui avait rapidement
précisé que la mère de du potentiel
assassin de Thomas était française
pourquoi euh quelques jours après ce
drame se sentir obligé d'apporter cette
précision dans dans le débat public je
je trouve que ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qui qui qui interroge en fait
alors les liens entre délinquence et
immigration je l'c tout à l'heure j'y
reviens ils sont évidemment au cœur de
cette polémique politique je vous
propose d'écouter un témoignage celui de
d'Alain beoher l'ancien directeur de
l'Observatoire de la délinquence voici
ce qu'il en dit l'Observatoire de la
délinquence quand je le dirigeais a
diffusé la statistique exacte des
étrangers mis en cause dans des affaires
de criminalité c'est assez facile plus
c'est grave moins il y en a en général
ils sont mis en cause essentiellement
pour leur statut irrégulier sur le
territoire ou pour des bagarres entre
eux ou pour des petits vols de
subsistance donc il faut aussi se
rappeler deuxièmement ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui des magrébains ou des
Africains on disait la même chose des
Polonais blonds aux yeux bleus
catholiques des Italiens ou des
Espagnols bruns aux yeux bruns
catholiques dans les mêmes manières les
journalistes de ce point de vue-là n'ont
pas beaucoup d'imagination dans l'idée
qu'ils se font de la représentation de
l'étranger dans leur part de crimin
finalement ça pose aussi la question des
statistiques ethniques Florent vadiillot
est-ce qu'il faut publier des
statistiques ethnique finalement pour
trancher ces questions là tout en tout
cas je je pense que il faut conduire le
débat j'ai pas de religion à la matière
mais je crois qu'il faut conduire le
débat elles ont été interdites en France
pour les meilleures raisons du monde
c'est-à-dire parce que c'était Vichy et
parce qu'ensuite lorsqu'elles sont
utilisé dans des régimes démocratique
elle en général elle soutend un modèle
qui est un modèle communautaire et qui
aux États-Unis par exemple donc c'est
pas le modèle universaliste fr c'est pas
le modèle universaliste français donc
c'est deux raisons l'une un peu
paroxistique et l'autre philosophique
les interdisaient aujourd'hui très
clairement ce que dit Alain Bauer est
partiellement vrai et et surtout
partiellement faux on pourrait y revenir
mais parce que il n'a pas les
statistiques si on prend les
statistiques de l'administration
pénitentiaire elles invalident le les ce
qu'il vient de dire puisqu'on a à peu
près un peu moins de 20 % de détenus
étrangers incarcérés en France et donc
ils ne le sont pas pour des Rix ou
autres il y a d'autres types de crimes
bon donc je pense que aujourd'hui vu que
le débat euh repose sur des fantasmes
repose sur des extrapolations et une
exploitation de la réalité une
distorsion volontairement orchestrée de
la politique je me demande s'il ne faut
pas envisager de recourir à ce genre de
statistiqu avec des gardes-fous absolus
qu'il faut définir mais qui permettrai
une bonne fois pour toutes d'établir une
véracité dans le débat chacun ensuite en
ferait son miel mais en tout cas que
l'on arrête de faire dire aux faits et
au chiffres parcellaires que l'on a une
vérité construite alors tout à l'heure
j'étais pas d'accord avec vous là je
suis d'accord avec vous je pense qu'on
en a besoin aujourd'hui de statistique
ethnique quel est votre avis je suis
assez d'accord avec vous et ça fait écho
je pense à une une opinion et un besoin
qu'on entend dans la bouche des français
quand on fait des enquêtes qualitatives
en fait on a appelé ça la France flou
sur l'immigration en particulier
beaucoup de gens nous disent au fond je
ne sais pas je n'ai pas une vision
claire sur ces sujets et sur tous ces
débats qui souvent enfl
notre notre débat public je pense qu'il
y a besoin effectivement de de se
référer à à des données claires et ça
explique aussi justement on parle de
fait divers là aujourd'hui ça explique
aussi le fait que de plus en plus les
Français ont un sentiment d'ilisibilité
de complexité de l'actualité en général
du monde de la politique et cetera et
que du coup il se raccroche au fait
divers on l'a entendu dans uneoc récente
une personne qui nous disait les fait
divers c'est plus réel parce que ce
serit et on va plus pardon vous
interromp on va plus croire un fait
divers qu'une statistique qui l'illustre
d'une certaine façon c'est un c'est un
peu ça alors enfin ou plutôt que des
grands chiffres des politiques publiques
ou des ou des des des débats finalement
complexes sur des sur des dynamiques de
société et c'est là que c'est toute la
c'est tout le le défi de réussir à lier
les deux en fait et de faire cette
pédagogie qui rapproche le micro du
macro h Victor de Lage faut-il publier
créer d'ailleurs autorisé puisque pour
l'instant effectivement c'est interdit
des statistiques éthniques en France moi
je crois effectivement par rapport à ce
qu' vient de dire dire ce qui vient
d'être dit pardon que ça pourrait être
être utile je je crois beaucoup moi à la
la compétence morale du peuple qui avait
été théorisé par le sociologue Raymond
Boudon euh qui se base notamment sur euh
la nécessité de se baser sur sur des
faits concrets de mettre cela à
disposition du public pour qu'ensuite
lui-même puisse trancher sur sur ce
qu'il en est on voit bien dans les
enquêtes d'opinion qu'on a beaucoup de
concitoyens aujourd'hui qui expriment
une crise de la représentation qu'elle
soit politique ou médiatique qui ont le
sentiment que ces acteursl ne parlent
pas forcément de de sujets qui les
concernent ou en tout cas pas de leur
quotidien qu'on leur cache même des
choses et c'est vrai que d'avoir accès à
ce type de données ça pourrait soit
battre en brèche ou soit confirmer
certaines idées qui sont relaté par
certains partis et je préciser justot
quand même sur le le risque de renforcer
le communautarisme parce que vous avez
anticipé la la critique tout à l'heure
c'est un risque réel quand même c'est un
risque réel mais je je voulais juste
finir et essayer à ce que vous dites par
il y a des pays en Europe qui qui qui
mettent à disposition ces données
notamment les pays nordiques et ça
permet justement de débattre sainement
de ces questions-là à gauche comme à
droite alors ce que beaucoup de de de
rapports montrent notamment au Danemark
mais aussi en Suède c'est que
l'augmentation de l'immigration euh
bah induit une augmentation de l'un des
dans ces pays-là en tout cas après sur
le risque de de communautarisme
peut-être mais il est déjà tellement
présent dans la société française pas
convaincu je suis pas convaincu je pense
que à l'heure de la de la POS vérité des
faits alternatifes de toute façon les
gens ne croient que ce qu'ils veulent
croire et donc remett en cause les
donnés officielles vous avez des gens
qui disent que les su du chômage sont
mensongés vous avez des gens enfin dans
le débat public hein des politiques donc
je pense que ça ne résoudra pas et puis
par ailleurs je pense que c'est aussi
renforcer une forme d'assignation
identitaire liê citoyen français on est
forcément tributaire de son origine et
les sta'est-ce qu'on est quand on est de
la 2è ou de laè génération est-ce qu'il
faut l'indiquer pas l'indiqué je trouve
qu'on est c'est c'est c'est poussé deux
choses qui qui me paraissent pas
judicieuses mais c'est d'un point de vue
très personnel ou mais c'est intéressant
tout le monde aura eu la la parole sur
sur sur cette question on vit côte à
côte je crains que demain on vive face à
face on va débattre et ce sera le
dernier chapitre de de ce premier débat
de sens public autour de cette
déclaration de de Gérard Colomb euh
l'ancien ministre de l'Intérieur
l'ancien maire de l' dont on a a pris le
décès ce ce weekend je vous propose de
de réécouter ce ce cet extrait c'était
euh lors de la passation de pouvoir il
avait démissionné du ministère de
l'Intérieur celui qui récupérait euh ses
prérogatif c'était le premier ministre
et de l'époque Édouard Philippe Gérard
Colomb je crois vraiment que dans la
périphérie parisienne on ne peut plus
continuer à travailler commune par
commune
il faut une vision d'ensemble pour
recréer de la mixité sociale parce que
aujourd'hui on vit côte à côte et je le
dis toujours moi je crains que demain on
vive face à face et donc nous sommes en
face de problèm immenses Mathieu on a
beaucoup cité reparlé de cette
déclaration de l'ancien maire de Lyon
oui et notamment à droite et à l'extrême
droite derric CTI Marion maréchal mour à
Marine Le Pen tous qui sont allés leur
hommage Postume à l'ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
qui qui critiquait vertement quand il
était place bovau pour son dénis son
inaction son angéisme mais l'occasion
était trop belle pour tous les chantes
du grand emplacement de l'AC de
l'accélérationnisme et autres chocs de
civilisation persuadé que la guerre
civile a commencé la semaine dernière à
la salle des fêtes de Crépol nous ne
vivrions donc plus côte à côte mais
face- à faceace selon les mots de
l'ancien maire de Lyon rebaptisé par
l'extrême droite pour l'occasion la
prophétie de Gérard Colomb et sans
hésiter par ailleurs d'une certaine
façon à trahir sa pensée alors pourquoi
expliquez-nous parce que Gérard Colomb
pr prenait le retour de l'ordre dans les
quartiers la chasse aux dealers la
défense d'uneicité ferme face à
l'islamisme politique mais on l'a
entendu dans l'extrait hein selon lui la
solution à ce face- à faceace des terres
elle viendrait par quoi par davantage de
mixité social je suis pas certain que ça
fasse ça ça réjouisse tous ceux qui ont
célébré sa petite phrase ce weekend
l'ancien mère de Lyon il savait de quoi
il parlait il était issu d'une famille
modeste faut le rappeler son père était
métalogétiste sa mère était femme de
ménage il était élu d'un quartier
populaire à Lyon et il a longtemps
incarné un courant dit réaliste quand il
était au Parti socialiste et cette
petite phrase il a d'ailleurs elle était
pas neuve hein il l'avait rodé déjà en
2015 dans un congrès du Parti socialiste
avant de la recycler auprès d'Emmanuel
Macron quand il lui fait donner des
notes et des phrases quand Emmanuel
Macron écrivait son livre de candidat
qui s'appelait révolution Emmanuel
Macron d'ailleurs repris mot à mot il
allait même encore plus loin Emmanuel
Macron dans ce livre puisque il parlait
à l'époque de lutter contre tout ce qui
fracture le pays et nous fait courir le
risque d'une guerre civile évidemment ce
n'était pas le premier président à Paris
de fracture ben non on se souvient
évidemment de Jacques Chirac en 95 sauf
que la sienne sa fracture si je peux me
permettre elle était avant tout sociale
mais plus près de nous François Hollande
aussi est allé de son petit couplet dans
son livre confidence vous savez un
président ne devrait pas dire ça il
évoquait lui un risque de parti comment
peut-on éviter la partition car c'est
quand même ça qui est en train de se
produire la partition il venait
d'évoquer l'islam et l'immigration on
voit bien de la droite à la gauche la
question sociale est passé derrière la
question identitaire merci Mathieu
Emmanuel Macron qui parle aussi de
décivilisation Laurence de ner que que
vous inspirent ces mots dans la bouche
du président de la République alors
cette expression a été largement
commentée on sait d'où elle vient mais
ensuite quel a été son chemin parce pas
faire abstraction de l'évolution de
l'usage des des termes Norbert Elias
bien sûr mais petit à petit elle a été
récupérée par l'extrême droite et c'est
dans ce contexte- làà que euh il faut
être conscient de de du sens qu'elle a
dans le débat public aujourd'hui je
pense que quand on parle de
décivilisation quand on parle
d'ensuvagement aussi à mon sens il y a
deux problèmes d'abord le problème de de
la généralisation on ne parle plus d'un
fait ou même d'une série de fait on
donne l'idée que c'est généralisé et
puis ça donne l'idée aussi d'une
tendance d'une évolution
h qu chose qui estvolutif et là ai on
extrapole interprète et c'est ça qui à
mon sens
et tout à fait discutable et etou mais
si c'est en train de se passer c'est pas
parce que l'extrême droite le dit qu'il
faut pas ça qui n'est pas justement
documenté quand c'est quand c'est
utilisé par par Emmanuel Macron voilà et
et là où c'est problématique c'est que
on sait on le voit pour le coup ces
termes qui sont de plus en plus présent
dans le débat public finissent par
devenir performatif en fait ils
finissent par en fait euh rendre réelle
euh une réalité une situation où tout le
monde est à couteau tiré où si on se
sent menacé finalement c'est quoi la
prochaine étape on veut finir comme les
américains ou la moitié des Américains
se sentent légitime à porter une arme
parce que ils se sentent menacés et la
loi les y autorise voilà vers quoi
veut-on aller donc euh le fait de
toujours euh euh pousser ce genre
d'image à mon sens euh nous emmène vers
ce rque victoire deage je voula ragir
non oui par rapport à ce terme de
décivilisation euh par rapport à ce qui
a été dit c'est il y a il y a Norbert
IAS effectivement qui a à l'origine de
de ce concept euh il est pas directement
arrivé euh dans l'oreille d'Emmanuel
Macron par ce qui se dit par l'extrême
droite c'est plutôt le politologue
Jérome Fourquet qui l'a repris justement
à son compte en montrant que sur bien
des aspects les dig une à une tombé
alors sur bien des aspects he que ça
soit par exemple sur les agressions à
l'égard des maires à l'égard des
médecins à l'égard de la police à
l'égard des pompiers qui représent
pourtant euh sein de la population ce
sont les derniers représentants un petit
peu des des institutions qui qui restent
populaires il y a aussi si vous voulez
une multiplication d'incivilité que l'on
observe un petit peu partout sur les
territoires et qui sont documentés une
défiance interpersonnel qui s'accroit
une défiance à l'égard de son voisin une
défiance à l'égard de de ses collègues
de bureau et par rapport à ce qui avait
été dit tout à l'heure justement je
crois que cette importation de cette
violence débridée dans C cette France
des territoires c'est quelque chose qui
qui qui choque qui met en etmoi toute la
population parce qu'on pensait que ça
resté que c'était les derniers
territoires qui étaient préservés de ce
type d'acte et c'est pas parce que vous
êtes dans un petit village de 500
habitant à une vingtaine de kilomètres
de de roman suriser que vous avez la
même sociologie il suffit de regarder le
comportement électoral de roman suriser
et de et de Crépol et vous verrez qu'il
y en a il y a un électorat qui a voté
mass Jean MCH au prier tour et un
électorat à CRP qui a voté à 30 % pour
Marine Le Pen au premier tour soit 7
points au dessus de la moyenne nationale
des civilisations flent vadiill alors on
a d'un côté qui ditah c'est pas vraiment
documenté vous vous nous dites un peu
l'inverse votre avis moi je pense que
c'est une faute politique parce que de
la part d'Emmanuel macronu TER oui parce
que un discours n'est jamais libre du
contexte d'énnonciation et tout le monde
sait que lorsque vous évoquez des
civilis
vous vous mettez dans un débat qui est
extrêmement codé et qui a été codé par
d'autres en l'espèce et moi je voudrais
qu' qu'on pose la question en fait donc
il reprend les mots du rassemblement il
reprend les mots encore une fois si le
phénomène existe j'y viens va pas le
laisser au au rassemblement national oui
mais pourquoi garder le prisme qui est
civilisationnel donc derrière ethnique
moi je pense que on est dans un pays qui
est aujourd'hui frappé d'immobilisme et
l'immobilisme il vaut pour une partie de
la population qui effectivement est en
forme de Sécession vis-à-vis de ce qui
fait une communauté de valeur mais il
vaut aussi pour la pauvreté aujourd'hui
quand vous êtes pauvre vous le restez et
on le voit il y a de moins en moins de
mobilité interclassis donc j'entends
qu'on qu'on qu'on qu'on veuille mettre
la focale sur un problème ethnique parce
que c'est une des convulsions de la
société et que globalement ceux qui ont
instrumenté ce termel s'en sortent mieux
dans les urnes sauf que ça ne représente
pas la réalité de l'ensemble des
problèmes du pays et surtout ça ne
représente même pas la complexité
elle-même du du du du du problème il y a
plein de communautés qui ont eu les
mêmes difficultés avec des taux de
délinquence importantes et qui au final
sont rentré totalement dans une norme
statistique pourquoi est-ce que on a ce
problème là de rupture parce que les
circonstances socio-économiques ont
changé aussi donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on
ne met pas l'accent sur le
socioéconomique pourquoi est-ce qu'on le
met sur le civilisationnel et
l'identitaire c'est un choix et ce
choix- là il a une conséquence sur le
débat donc sur la manière dont il est
perçu par les électeurs Laurence un mot
de conclusion est-ce qu'il y a une sorte
d'offensive euh idéologique et active de
l'extrême droite c'estd qu'on on a vu et
François Holland qui était ce matin sur
franço faisait le lien ce qui s'est
passé à Dublin après une attaque au
couteau d'un ressortissant irlandais
d'origine algérienne manifestation ultra
violente de de l'extrême droite et puis
là on a vu ce qui s'est passé à
romoniriser ou dans d'autres villes de
France est-ce que c'est une sorte
d'offensive concertée ou pas forcément
oui très clairement il y a une offensive
et qui est assez largement efficace
c'est ça qui est qui est qui est grave
et et pour autant qui est en décalage
avec ce que pensent une grande partie
des Français et en fait c'est ce dont il
s'agit c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est notre rapport à
l'information aujourd'hui l'information
n'est plus tellement considérée comme
une une séquence une série de faits
qu'il s'agit d'établir et d'analyser
mais plutôt comme en fait un outil un
instrument pour conforter des visions du
monde et ça c'est extrêmement dangereux
donc c'est un des sujets sur lesquels
travaille en ce moment les états
généraux de l'information auquel je je
contribue et pour en revenir à ce que
disait ce que vous à l'instant on a
documenté récemment on a demandé aux
Français selon vous quelles sont les
divisions les plus importantes qui
traversent la société française
aujourd'hui la division entre les
personnes issues de l'immigration et les
personnes nées en France ou française
quel que soit le terme qu' n'arrive pas
du tout en premier ni et c'est beaucoup
plus loin derrière l'opposition entre la
France des villes et la France des
campagnes celle qui arrive en premier
c'est l'opposition entre les riches et
les pauvres donc là je vous rejoins il
faut il faut revenir aux fondamentaux et
dépasser des cadrages qui nous sont
imposés systématiquement et sur ce thème
cette information qui nous parvient à
l'instant cette fin d'après-midi six
participants de ces euh manifestations
j'emplois terme là à roman sur riser
donc militants d'extrême droite ont été
condamnés aujourd'hui à des peines
allant de 6 à 10 mois de prison euh
ferme merci à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat et je vous dis à bientôt sur
Public Sénat